[Music]
for decades the minimum wage has sparked
fierce debate
among economists and politicians
the covert 19 pandemic and president joe
biden's push to raise america's minimum
wage
have forced the issue back into the
political spotlight
economists traditionally believed that
raising the minimum wage
led to job losses it's often been feared
the minimum wage will end up hurting the
very people you're trying to help
yet decades of research has led to a
rethink
and today 90 of countries have some form
of minimum wage
[Music]
but there is still no agreement on how
high it can be without harming workers
why does the minimum wage continue to be
so divisive
[Music]
for more than a hundred years worker
revolutions and strikes fought for a
minimum wage
in 1894 new zealand finally introduced
the first laws
around a national base pay since then
take up of minimum wages in the rest of
the world has been varied
though the concept is simple workers are
paid a legal base rate for their work
most economists believed the minimum
wage could destroy jobs
this idea comes from the most basic of
economic models
supply and demand economics 101
if you make something more expensive
people will usually want to buy less of
it
and if you make labor more expensive
then employers might want less of it
and what we call employers wanting less
labor in the real world
is unemployment america's first
federal minimum wage wasn't introduced
until 1938
when president franklin roosevelt set it
at 25 cents per hour
to help low-income workers during the
great depression
[Music]
but the federal minimum wage in america
isn't tied to inflation
and so hasn't kept up with rising prices
over time it's lost value and stagnated
today it stands at 7.25 per hour
meaning that in real terms it peaked at
around 12
in 1968
[Music]
in response to the low federal minimum
wage rate
some state and county politicians raised
it locally themselves
by the early 1990s instead of having
just one us minimum wage
you've got differing minimum wages in
different states different counties
different cities so almost this
patchwork quilt of differing wage floors
in 1991 the federal minimum wage in
america went up to 4.25
about eight dollars in today's money
by 1992 24 states had the same minimum
wage rate as the federal one and
five states had minimum wage rates
higher than it
this patchwork of different minimum wage
levels gave economists an opportunity
to measure the real-world impact of the
minimum wage
and this led to a study that turned
economic thinking about the minimum wage
on its head in 1992
two economists from princeton david card
and alan kruger
looked at how changes to the minimum
wage affected employment at fast food
restaurants
in two states with differing policies
new jersey where the minimum wage for
workers
increased and neighboring pennsylvania
where it stayed the same
of course what conventional theory would
tell you at the time is
the minimum wage has gone up in new
jersey it hasn't gone up in pennsylvania
what you'd expect to see is employment
in new jersey
to fall relative to employment in
pennsylvania
but what kardon kruger found is actually
the opposite
despite the wage going up in new jersey
employment actually increased
the surprising result can be explained
by the idea of monopsony power
something that employers in the fast
food industry may possess
to a degree in a monopoly
there is one dominant supplier who sells
to many buyers
a monopsony is the opposite there's one
sole buyer of goods
or employer of workers the classic
example
is a one factory town but all employers
have a degree of monopsony power
in this case the fast food company in an
area
with less competition the employer can
set the wage for their workers
this means wages can be kept
artificially low
carden kruger found that a small wage
increase didn't lead to redundancies
because wages were already below market
rate
and why did employment increase the
higher wage may have attracted new
workers to the market
the study proved for the first time that
raising the minimum wage doesn't
necessarily destroy
jobs this groundbreaking finding
challenged conventional wisdom on
minimum wages in america
and saw similar policies spread around
the world
china introduced a minimum wage in 1994
britain in 1998 along with ireland in
2000
and germany in 2015
cards and kruger's finding also led to a
new focus on empirical
or real world data as opposed to theory
yet gathering empirical data isn't easy
and can give contradictory results
so far from providing clarity the study
only served to reignite the debate
so are you going to track the number of
jobs or are you going to track
workers because you know they're not
necessarily the same thing
you've got to decide are you going to
try and look at the entire labor market
or just certain groups whether that be
the low skilled or teenagers
or some other sort of group isolating
the impact of the minimum wage
is far from straightforward
take seattle it's been at the forefront
of the minimum wage debate in america
since a historic law in 2014 was passed
that would set the minimum wage at 15
an hour by 2021
two studies of low paid jobs a year
apart gave very different results
the first published in 2017 looked at
aggregate data
or averages of data on hours and
earnings
it found that the increase in minimum
wage led to employers reducing hours in
low paid sectors
meaning employees overall lost out on
monthly wages
the second in 2018 looked at individual
workers
and found that low-paid workers earned
more on a weekly basis
after the minimum wage had been
increased but some of this gain was
because workers were picking up shifts
in other jobs so in their first
paper they're looking at aggregated
number of hours aggregated number of
jobs
aggregated numbers about pay but a year
later in their second paper
they've got access to these individual
tax records so they can actually track
what's happening to individuals and
follow them
both studies are accurate but seemingly
contradictory
this goes to the heart of the minimum
wage debate
fundamentally what these two studies
show is that the minimum wage is really
an empirical question
rather than a theoretical one it depends
on what sectors people are working in
how easily replaced by machines they are
what sort of profit margins their
employers have
what their pricing power is and what
policy makers and economists need to
keep in mind
is that they need to keep checking the
data keep looking at different types of
data
and keep examining the evidence of the
impact these policies are having
and in america the opportunity for
another experiment could be just around
the corner
this time on a national scale
i'm joe biden it's time we had a 15
an hour minimum wage so families can
earn a living
and get ahead as president i'll make
sure we get it done
raising the federal minimum wage to 15
an hour
isn't just about economics this is about
politics this is a partisan dividing
line
and you know he may struggle to push
this through the senate
it would take america's economy into
uncharted waters
and some economists still fear it is too
high for firms to handle
and could lead to job losses if joe
biden does manage to raise the federal
minimum wage to 15
an hour that'll obviously be a big
historical moment
but i'm afraid economists and
politicians
will likely be arguing about the impact
for years to come
the world has little experience of an
increase this large
perhaps analyzing the impact could help
economists finally reach a consensus
on the minimum wage
i'm duncan wilder britton economics
correspondent at the economist
we've written a series of articles on
the basics in economics
and how the latest research and thinking
is changing them
you can find those articles at the link
below thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe